WN jetzt alles für dieam Brache das
Szenario
Bürgerkriegen Flucht Weg
molei
m
km der Schweizer las Achermann wohn seit
Jahren in
ostsirien tausende Kilometer weg von der
Ukraine und doch irgendwie nahe am
Krieg einheimisch erzählen dass hier oft
Flugzeuge landen die verletzte Kämpfer
von der ukrainischen Front
zurückbringen aber auch der Tod ist hier
allgegenwärtig
über 2000 Kämpfer aus der Region des
baikalseegebietes sollen in der Ukraine
bereits gefallen sein
[Applaus]
nur ein paar autominen entfernt vom
Friedhof wird schon die nächste
Generation auf den Krieg
[Musik]
vorbereitet
militärfreizeitparks wie diesen gibt es
schon seit längerem doch jetzt kommen
neue Helden
hinzu die Teilnehmer an der sogenannten
militärischen
spezialoperation schon nur aus dieser
Region zu berichten ist schwierig
geworden doch Lukas Achermann will hier
weiterleben ich irgend
auch W ich befundet B und und und
bevölker da auch nicht FA dass ich
einfach aus dem Grund einfach
irgendwo find nicht
ein
die Möglichkeit Schwiz wieder für mich
bequemste ist sondern irgendwo finde ich
mich wie mit den B solidarisieren und
zeig hoff verloren sind alles Mörder und
[Musik]
schlechter was bedeutet es für den
Luzerner aber auch für die Einheimischen
in einem Land zu leben das einen
Angriffskrieg
führt
[Musik]
will
Spiel ja
[Musik]
hallo danke
gut
Schwester schwitz
wunderbar sie und die ganz Familie s
sehr stolz auf Dich ich dir sagen
Danke Sibirien lässt niemanden kalt
unter diesem Motto startete Achermann
2016 seine erste lastwagenreise nach
Russland begleitet von
SRF einem zum Wohnwagen umgebauten
Lastwagen machte er sich auf in Richtung
Osten ich mir schon die Kindheit a W ich
den ein schwer mit dem L quer das
Russland fahre bis Pazifik und wieder
zurück das ist e mal mit Traum ges hat
denau Nacht muss Flich andere bettdeck
irgendwelche Atlanten me Strecke auskt
und ich mit dem L und ich selber umbauen
werd wir
fahreen über 8000 km sind es von Luzern
bis zum
Baikalsee diese Reise machte er dann
mehrmals mit Touristen 2018 übersiedelte
er definitiv nach Sibirien und ließ sich
in der Nähe des größten süßwassersees
der Welt nieder zuerst kurz in irkutz
dann in ulanud der Hauptstadt der
russischen Republik
burizien
ja das
istm
bescheiden Heim schön und da der
nachbarch aber 15 jah schon in
Russland russische Frau da von der
gagendan Z sind auf Deutschland igriert
die Deutland n
no ja vor allem Schul
sch irendwi schwierigde mit der
Schu ja offenbar
Hal ich sag viel
Patriotismus wir
[Musik]
doch ursprüngliches Ziel war für
Kleinstgruppen ausgiebige sibirienreisen
im beikalgebiet zu
[Musik]
organisieren sind meistens so z bis D wö
g ich
gemacht
und
das ja es hat funktioniert das ist
Russland ist schon immer schwierig sie
zum l finden sind ist mit so wahnsinnige
verurteil
behaftetteil ja Russland das ist
gefählich da jetzt sind alleof das ist
nur Mafia und S ist nur korrupt und muss
das Leben fürchten und das ist alles
grau und nur furchtbar und das stimmt
natürlich h vor
nicht sind extrem net sind sehr
gastfreundlich sind zu vorkommend hab
wirklich Freud auch jetzt immer noch
wenn Europäer kom ja also auch die
jetzige Situation ich persönlich spüre
nicht ke ich ke Repression s schon
unterscheiden was Politik und was L
sind
natürlichum sein Traumfahrzeug hat er
anfangs
2022 gekauft nur wenige Tage vor dem
russischen Einmarsch in der
Ukraine us macht wieder für vier l also
das ma schlafen und alles ja ja das Trin
also es ist wirklich so g die Euphorie
wolich
die Pandemie dur so jetzt jetzt g
vorwärts und D kam es noch
schlimmerürich gemacht investier ke
Franken bringt nicht komt also meine
europäische Tourismus da kann auf die
näch bis 15 jah vergessen in dem Land
das war
fahen ist schon paar einzelmasken aber
der muss ist vor schon schwierig
Dasha nach Russland den nach
Sibirien nach Sibir nach wir
braucht und noch für etwas ist Sibirien
bekannt ein schirunendliches Reservoir
an Soldaten die beikalreion ist zusammen
mit dem Kaukasus einer der wichtigsten
rekrutierungsorte auch während der
Teilmobilmachung
da wönsjd stattgefunden ja also morgen Z
sind
dieagop halb Stund ne ja diese mit
Helikopter hab W gesucht und
so kan nicht vorstellen und das weiß ich
V direk
betroffenind men
stattgefunden alle
gefunden me sag zum
Krieg F no schwiig wird nein nein
das
groß wir können heute miterleben mit
Lukas jetzt sein Geld verdient geplant
ist ein Tagesausflug mit rund zwe dutzen
sibirischen Seniorinnen einer Gruppe die
sich regelmäßig
trifft doch zuerst noch ein
obligatorischer
Zwischenstopp so z sogenannte
medosmotor medizinische untersuchig das
ist vor jeder fahr am Morgen muss man
zum zum Fahrtauglichkeit bestätig
guten Tag guten
Tag wir drehen seine
Reise eine
Reise so wie geht es ihn blutuck es geht
mir
gut50
perfekt
fertig danke auf
wiedersehenen und temperaturmassen und
so das sch nein das geht so schn vi zu
stell
vor Stempel jaempelterchrift fertig also
glaube s se sch fah oder wenn ich
mitmen oder
irgendwie
den ja ja das geh me um das ja ja vor
allem ja spitzenlöhne für freiwillige
vertragssoldaten solche Werbebanner
trifft man in ganz
Russland hallo hallo hallo guten Morgen
hörst du mich guten Morgen Ich bin
gleich da am Parkplatz vor meinem Haus
wo bist du
jetzt ich bin gleich
da an verschiedenen Haltestellen der
Stadt anud sammelt Lukas seniorinen
auf immer dabei seine Hündin
Stella ich habe für Ihren Hund Knochen
gebracht hier direkt aus dem Gefrierfach
sie sind kalt gut ja ich habe hier einen
Kühlschrank danke
vielmals sie braucht doch was zum
Mittagessen sie kommt doch immer mit
oder ja genau warum wird
gefilmt das sind die vom Schweizer
Fernsehen oh dann werde ich in der
Schweiz
gezeigt ja
ja hallo
hallo wie geht's
gut liebe ich habe dir zu Essen
mitgebracht kann man das so horizontal
hinlegen ja kann man guten Tag wir sind
die Delegation aus der
Schweiz die Frauen im Bus wen von mir wi
warum noch ledig sei sort
allesen
das große
Thema warum B
fr das geht doch nicht d
keinener auch im Tourismusbereich bei
unserem Besuch war sie allerdings auf
Geschäftsreise immer weitere Frauen
kommen hinzu es ähnelt einem Ausflug in
der
Schweiz aber die Gespräche sie sind vom
Krieg
geprägt mein Schwiegersohn wurde von der
Front zu den
untersseh
erurdeusinel ose mit Sprengstoff
getreten eine Explosion hat ihm seinen
Fuß abgetrennt und unser hatte eine Kopf
und eine
Knieverletzung man muss
aufpassen ja aber die beiden wurden
ausgezeichnet 100 Tote neun sind
geflohen und zwei haben
überlebt ihr Schwiegersohn habe jetzt
eine Wohnung im besetzten ukrainischen
Gebiet erhalten jenseits der Front er se
dort in der
Verwaltung vwnt vermeidet den Kontakt
mit den
Frauen wenn ihr sie zurückweiß dann
zeigen sie euch wegen Vergewaltigung
[Musik]
an unser Held steht auf dem Plakat
geschrieben also wir fahren jetzt da
über Fluss selenga da komus der Mongolei
ist00 km lang und ist die größte Zufluss
vom beikse also da bringt am meist
Wasser die beik der 350 zfü und das ist
der größte da gerade der Berg von der
Hirsche das ist ein buddhistische
schamanistische heiligen Ort aber wir
das and
andiel man spürt Lukas fühlt sich wohl
in burizien diese Republik mit knapp
einer Million Einwohnern wo die Russen
zwar in der Mehrheit sind aber die
buriatische Kultur dennoch eine zentrale
Rolle spielt die buriaten sind
mehrheitlich
Buddhisten
Zwischenhalt für mich der Moment erste
Kontakte zu knüpfen hier bei
traditioneller buriatischer Küche
erfahre ich dass fast jede Teilnehmerin
Verwandte oder Bekannte an der
ukrainischen Front
[Musik]
hat die erste Sehenswürdigkeit die
buddhistische Klosteranlage bulumurski
dazan der Tempel war zu stahlinzeiten
zerstört worden und die Priester
ermordet oder verhaftet
mit viel Herzblut wurde das Kloster in
den letzten Jahren wieder
aufgebaut die meisten Frauen in
lukasguppe sind eigentlich keine
buddhistinnen aber sie machen die
Rituale gerne mit und das Wasser hier
soll wahre Wunder wirken erzählt man
uns es hilft ganz sicher bei vielen
Krankheiten
magheiten ein Kranker soll am Morgen am
Mittag und am Abend dieses Wasser
trinken man kann damit auch Tee oder
Suppe
kochen nach ein zwei Monaten geht es ihm
besser er läuft wieder herum und singt
Lieder das sagen
alle Marina erzählt mir von den Kämpfen
in die ihr Schwiegersohn verwickelt
war
unsere Herzen werden zerrissen wir
verlieren unsere Söhne Ehemänner
Brüder wie
weiter ich persönlich glaube an
Putin sein Aussehen ist sehr
glaubwürdig ich kenne zwar sein Team
nicht von Politik verstehe ich wenig
aber Putin ja er trägt nicht umsonst den
schwarzen
judoürtel sie glauben ihm
ja ihm glaube
ich und was hält man bei euch von der
spezialoperation in der
Schweiz na ja wir sind ja neutral aber
wir machen bei den europäischen
Sanktionen
mit gegen Russland aber warum wird
Russland jetzt gehasst vielleicht gibt
es dafür ja einen Grund nun im Westen
hält man das für ein Angriffskrieg gegen
diehäige
UNO hat den Angriff verurteilt und die
Schweiz hat auch
zugestimmt aber Waffen liefen wir
nicht mit Wagner das war auch eine
interessante Geschichte
nicht Themenwechsel sobald es
kompliziert
wird wenn Lukas mit Passagieren alleine
spricht ä sich manche
kritisch
die Situation sind die meist nicht Verst
also Verst nicht
wieso
wieso Verst nicht was das das ist
eigentlich
soens Situation Verst
nicht dann geht die Fahr durch dastische
Hinterland
weiter schöne Region aber auch eine der
ärmsten in
Russland beachliche
Landflucht viel pensioniert no
da
Kön got
eigent D die Station
istkut
derir der Moskau und die die ganz schlau
die schaffen B auf Europa oder
Nordamerika
also Verl das Verl einfach
[Musik]
unduine große Plan und
den
allesangen
ist
und perspektiv geh Form
[Musik]
so eine weitere buddhistische
Klosteranlage
taminskan ein bedeutendes religiöses
Zentrum des Buddhismus in
burizien hier gibt es noch Gebäude die
den stalinistischen Terror überstanden
hatten schlägt jemand auf die
Trommel das Filmteam möchte gerne die
Trommel
hören diese Flasche ist eigentlich fürs
heilige Wasser ist das
Wodka nein fürs heilige Wasser natürlich
das heilige Wasser wird im Sommer in
leere Flaschen
abgefüt
[Musik]
skurile Momente wechseln sich ab mit
überraschend offenen
Gesprächen wie ist es mit Lukas unserem
Schweizer gut
zufrieden ja er ist ein interessanter
Mann es ist sehr interessant mit ihm zu
sprechen wir waren ja nie im
Ausland es interessiert uns alles wo was
wie es kommen ja jetzt weniger westliche
Ausländer hierher wegen dieser Situation
sind die Menschen hier in
Sorge ja
natürlich jeder Familie ist jemand
dorthingegangen auch a ihr Familie ja
wer denn mein Schwiegersohn der Ehemann
mein teren Tochter ein Offizier und mein
Bruder ist
dort
da ist man besorgt aber
natürlich ständig denke ich darüber bete
zünde Kerzen in der Kirche
an ich bete auch zu
Hause und ich
helfe wir haben vor kurzem tnetze
geflochten und an die Front
geschickt gibt es auch welche die gegen
die spezialoperation
sind ja
schon es gibt solche die sagen für was
soll man dortthingehen die sollen doch
dort ihre Probleme selber
lösen ja ja kommen sie
nur und in den Familien gibt es da auch
Diskussionen es gibt Diskussion
natürlich an der Arbeit wird diskutiert
zu Hause wird diskutiert Fernehen
schauen wir aber schon länger nicht mehr
dies
nachrichtendungen eineig und in
Wirklichkeit sieh ganz anders
aus also irgendwie
so
so lieber nicht
weiter später sagt mir noch drei
ehemalige Mitschüler sein bereits
umgekommen im
Krieg dann wieder die sibirische
Gastfreundschaft die Lukas und auch mir
eigentlich so gut
gefällt Käse in
Fladenbrot sehr gut
Töchterchen schenkt den Männern
ein Nein Danke wir sind am
Steuer zur Erinnerung das ist unser
buchen herzlichen
Dank und das sind unsere typischen
sibirischen Geschenke sie müssen abends
dieenkerne aus den Zapfen knacken und
essen
vielen
Dank ein wirklich schöner Tag und doch
spürt man es ist etwas da das uns trennt
ein russischer Soziologe sprach kürzlich
vom Krieg als Elefant im Raum alle ihn
aber man will ihn nicht
beachten meine Reise geht hier zu Ende
und ich kehre in die Schweiz
zurück aber ein paar Wochen später reist
mein russischer Kameramann jefgeni noch
mal nach
ulanude Lukas hat einen schwierigen aber
auch spannenden Besuch vor sich
Tima ein guter Freund von ihm sie nennen
sich gegenseitig Brüder ist freiwillig
in den Krieg
gezogen Lukas will Dimas Mutter nadesta
besuchen um Erklärungen für diese
Entscheidung zu
finden in seinem russischen Kleinbus
einer buchanka auf deutschkastenbrot
fährt er zum Baikalsee wo Dimas Haus
ist kurz vor dem Treffen rufe ich ihn
aus der Schweiz aus
an aber wie ist das für dich das
schm ja es ist für mich ziemlich heftig
also
ja aber ist wirklich Freund von mir und
ich hat das eigentlich nicht
dankt D so macht
und
nicht ke warum
kann aber einfach überrascht muss so
sagen wir überrascht und ja
irgendwie schockiert und ich das
erfahr mich nicht lustig und
ich und
[Musik]
wie die Mutter von Dima wohnt nah in
einem kleinen
Dorf heute ist noch eine Freundin zu
[Musik]
Besuch du bist
einach da kann keine
frauten jetzt trinke ich gerne einen Tee
mit ich weiß nicht wie das auf Russisch
heißt aber das ist eine typische
Schweizer Spezialität eigentlich mit
Haselnüssen aber diese haben auch
Pinienkerne drin nach sibirischer
Art so
fein er braucht doch keine
Frau wohnen sie
allein hast du etwas Neues von di gehört
ja er ruft selbst an aber sehr selten
wann war
das am
sechsten sich verändert sein Kopf ist
rasiert ich mache mir große Sorgen du
machst dir
Sorgen jetzt stell dir vor wie ich als
Mutter mir Sorgen mache und wie geht es
dir in dieser
Situation wie kann es mir gehen ich bete
nur und hoffe auf Gottes
Gnade und was meinen Sie
dazu
ich n er hat mir bis zur letzten Minute
nichts
gesagt er wollte mich auf seine Art
vorbereiten er hatte sich schon auf den
Krieg
eingestellt das sind seine alten Fotos
er war schon immer ein
waffenfan wir haben früher einmal am
baikalse Schießübungen
gemacht egen dass in den Krieg
zieht er ist der Mann im
Haus da ist
er ja hat das letzte Wort nicht
ich ein junger Mann der sich gerade ein
Haus baut und ein gutgehendes Geschäft
hat zieht in den Krieg warum nur will
kamermanngen
wissen hatten sie nicht den Wunsch ihren
Sohn davon abzuhalten damit er nicht in
den Krieg
zieht in Russland so viel Land so viele
Aufgaben die zu erledigen
sind warum sterben dort so viele unserer
Jungs bald gibt's hier keine
mehr er ist nicht mehr jung er ist
34 er hat seine
Meinung natürlich war es schmerzhaft für
mich ich hatte Angst immer noch ich bin
sehr
beuncht aber ich verstehe ihn auch er
hatte ja dort Freunde viele sind ums
Leben gekommen er meint wie kann er hier
ein Haus bauen wie kann er hier Business
machen wenn seine Freunde dort ums Leben
kommen seine
brü ich habe unterwegs hierher viele
junge Soldaten
gesehen die hin und her
fliegen und ich frage mich warum diese
Menschen ihre unwrtliche Heimat
verlassen
wo es doch noch so viel zu tun
GBE warum sind Sie bereit ihr Leben zu
opfern um in ein fremdes Land zu gehen
warum finden Sie hier keine Verwendung
für sich
warum die Ukraine ist kein fremdes Land
das ist unser Russland unsere Brüder wir
kämpfen dort nicht gegen die Ukrainer
sondern gegen die amerikanischen
Besatzer
[Musik]
in einem letzten Telefonat mit Lukas
merke ich wie er versucht Verständnis
für die Aussagen von Dimas Mutter
aufzubringen was S unterstütz dem S und
da muss es irgendwie auch bis kurz bed
oder ja man W natürlich einfach per se
ablehen es muss irgende Grund irgendetas
passiert nicht
saggab ja wie ist das jetzt für dich
also wir dem FM Thema
so der Kollektiv
Verantwortig Freund frewiig
geh macht schuldig
die ja gut jetzt natürlich diskutiere
was ist Schuld ich find das ganze
schwieriges
Thema Kollektiv
verantworttig das W natürlich Gicht vom
Land von der belossig von der Propaganda
belossig so Kindesalter ist es sch find
ich verdamm schwieriges
Thema ja und ein
Straß ist alles scheiße
das sch aber
W Konsequenzen wei wo ein erwartet dann
macht einfach
nicht aber meineber das isttin Brüder ja
Freund und jetzt in wir hier in der
schwitz oder im West mehrheitlich klar
verurteile ja also ich verurteil das
eigentlich auch aber ich mir
nur wieder gesund
und sonderm zurückkt oh große psychische
schade
ja und ich mag ih trotzdem n Mensch ich
weiß g Mensch ist und aber es ist
natürlich für mich jetzt
sch mer weniger persönlicheit W ich ich
nicht einfach so einfach verdrangen wie
vor will ich jetzt wirklich ich sehr gut
mag
wo äh ja kan vor
[Musik]
frontis lieber und so geht es Lukas
Achermann hier am weikalsee einlich wie
Millionen von Menschen in ganz
Russland am liebsten hätten sie gar
nichts mit dem Krieg zu tun aber
ausblenden können sie nicht denn der
Krieg durchdringt zwischen ihr ganzes
[Musik]
Leben